what's up everyone
Mike McCarty here with gamespot news
update today CD Projekt RED revealed the
witcher threes biggest patch to date and
that's kind of an understatement the
developer wasn't kidding when it said
patch one point the update represents
the largest collection of fixes
improvements and enhancements introduced
to the witcher 3 there are 600 PC slash
console changes in all which is spread
across quests stability inventory
management and additional fan-requested
romance options the change log which can
be found on the developers forums is
nearly 13 pages long and it doesn't even
represent all the changes coming to the
game with this patch CD Projekt RED
hasn't announced a release date yet but
community manager Martian Lamott said in
the forum post that it should land in a
matter of days so hopefully we will see
it before October 13th when the game's
first paid expansion launches I
personally review hearthstone and I gave
it a 9 trust me it's well worth the
return to northern kingdoms so what do
you think our patch notes this long
enough to get you back to the witcher 3
if not go play hearthstone read my
review the expansion is really good I'm
actually gonna go play more of it right
now
in the meantime Jake